Roger Goodell is now down here because
he get he did the boys that got to get
it right speech that's when you know
you're in trouble and the NFL's when you
just stay on there I don't know what
that means we've got to get it right we
didn't get it right we're gonna work on
trying to get it right so next time we
got to get it right I'm embarrassed for
my actions embarrass for the league
Barris for anyone on the same cotton
that is me you didn't get it right we
got to get it right next time we're
gonna work on getting right starts with
that and then the next day the guys on
the sports talk radio you know the Andy
and Dan guys yeah that connects all
their thoughts with that like they came
out the first corner and they were all
those guys jump on it
we will just say where's what is the
league but look at a message when a
message you they send it out like I
don't know it's like what what message
are they said to know do you think I'm
gonna I'll see this guy hit a woman and
then I'm gonna do it right right right I
wasn't going to hit a woman but then
that guy and the Ravens did so I guess
it's okay
they got a real problem it drove me nuts
the whole month they got a real problem
the NFL it's compared to what plumbers
electricians society in general there's
a lot of great people that play football
the league's gonna be fine like what
they would have to do - I was talking to
my buddy go today like what they would
have to do to get me to stop watching
you know like love football you want the
Commissioner could literally punt a baby
across this office with his wing tips on
Sunday I don't condone the man's ass but
it's football I have to watch it this is
all I have
you